tesla will move its headquarters to
texas elon musk says this is a cnn story
i'm excited to announce that we're
moving our headquarters to austin texas
says elon musk at a shareholder meeting
the electric car company is currently
based in palo alto california he cited
housing affordability and the long
commutes it can create as hurdles for
its current location and said the austin
factory is five minutes away from the
airport in 15 minutes from downtown the
median home prices in palo alto is 3.3
million dollars
whereas the median home prices in austin
is 5.88 let me say that one more time
the median home prices is 3.3
million dollars to 588 despite the move
musk said tesla plans to continue to
significantly expand in california i
think the last comment was made to say
don't hurt me yet till i fully leave
your state it's an insurance policy
of a comment so how many more stories
like this is going to happen because
california you guys heard what uh
california is doing there's some very
weird stories yeah rece it's almost
unbelievable like when i read it i
thought tom ellsworth was sending me
another one of his you know by the way
when's the last time you running austin
but two weeks ago you were there yeah i
was there two weeks ago as well
i have a point
um
i have a point i i obviously was very
awkward the way he did it but
well i have something to say because i
grabbed the grab the box of cookies
san francisco san jose silicon valley uh
palo alto silicon silicon silicon valley
hello silicon it's crazy crazy expensive
i get it i get it
austin
you can quote me on this they're going
to be dealing with the same issues
they're dealing with california pretty
soon affordability oh yeah homelessness
and traffic that's all i experienced in
austin i'm like i'm ready to have a good
time in austin yeah yeah traffic galore
things are expensive homeless galore
yeah okay so
just
be careful what you wish for elon musk
and people in texas because california
is coming forward college teammate sean
finnegan left jersey for uh
austin texas about 10 years ago and he
was a real estate agent dudes made money
like through the roof man doing
mortgages and real estate and he said
now it's like it's it's nuts it's insane
they never thought to build another road
the infrastructure is still like 20
years old but now they're just building
on top of each other like it's to keep
austin weird is it's uh now it's like
please move out of austin the people
there
nancy our graphic designer said i want
you to play a game while you're in
austin
homeless or hipster hipster homeless i
half the time i'm like that guy's
clearly hit no he's homeless i gotta
tell that guy probably i'm a millionaire
same thing it's homeless or hipster the
lady i got my condo from thought she got
one over on me man she was like you're
gonna pay this for that and i'm paying i
pay 100
more 100 more a month i had a 700 square
foot loft on the hudson river in in
jersey city i pay 100 more for a
two-bedroom 2500 square foot two-bedroom
two-bath condo here in pompano and
you're on the beach i'm on the beach and
i haven't i haven't stepped over one
hole i haven't smelled it you know
your friends in new jersey florida's not
good they don't need to come here
don't investigate for yourself there's
nothing good going on everybody's like
the markets in new jersey are 100 more
for a two bedroom as opposed to you know
denver's the same way like to be honest
i used to live downtown and at one point
i was like
man there's a lot of homelessness and
then sheree and i go down there we're
like no these are hipsters so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you